[Music]
lumber has never been more expensive
two by fours are more than three times
their typical price
other wood products that we use to build
houses like plywood have also soared
the increases are thanks to an
unexpected boom in demand
even in the broad rally that has pushed
up commodity prices across the board
from crude oil to corn the dramatic
climb in wood prices stands out
lumber futures have more than tripled
since the rally began in april 2020.
no one expected wood prices to soar not
even sawmills lumber dealers
and others who profit from rising prices
here's how lumber prices climb to
records during the pandemic
who is profited and why those who grow
the trees haven't benefited at all
when the pandemic set in sawmill shut
down like many other businesses
before the lockdown it was shaping up to
be a strong home building season
but when the global economy ground to a
halt in 2020
new housing construction in the u.s
plummeted
at the onset of the pandemic lumber mill
shut down
dealers liquidated their inventories and
speculators started shorting
lumber futures expecting prices to
plunge no one thought that there was a
housing boom coming
or a remodeling boom hunker down
homeowners remodeled in mass
and low mortgage rates drove demand for
suburban housing
while restaurants raced to construct
outdoor dining accommodations
lumber and plywood started flying off
shelves the building boom lifted the
share price of home improvement giant's
lows and hope depot
ahead of the broader market wood was in
short supply
sawmills ramped up capacity but couldn't
catch up leading to a surge in prices
besides prices rising demand is such
that some people can't even get
the right amounts or the right products
of lumber and you're seeing this
throughout
you know across products from a 2x4 to
plywood to engineered products for home
builders
sawmills have been big beneficiaries
owners of southern mills have seen
profits skyrocket
and their share prices have surged
farther up the wood supply chain
those who grow the trees that become the
two by fours have been left out
timber growers supply mills with logs
which are sawed into lumber and mashed
into pulp
prices for logs and lumber usually move
in unison
but lately their prices have diverged
much of the nation's logs are harvested
in the u.s south
and southern growers have gained nothing
from the run-up in prices for finnish
lumber
earl and wanda bars have been growing
timber for 35 years in central georgia
they say prices for their timber have
not kept pace with the run-up in lumber
the landowner us we haven't benefited
from the
increase in the price of lumber when i
was a procurement forester
uh we were paying uh 25
a ton for a saw timber uh
on the stump 40 years ago and if you
bring that forward today
the market is 25 or less on the stump
today and that's in constant dollars
that's not taking into account inflation
and other
things that have gone up to grow those
trees the problem is that there's so
many trees
between 1980 and 2020 the volume of wood
per acre of timberland in many southern
counties has more than quadrupled
in the 1980s the federal government paid
a lot of landowners in the south to
plant trees
the government wanted to take cropland
out of rotation and
and to stop having a lot of corn and
soybeans so the prices would rise in
those markets
and they paid people to grow trees
because those trees would sit on the
land for decades
and just grow and accumulate value and
eventually be ready to be made into
things like lumber and plywood
decades later many of those trees are
being harvested which has flooded the
market with an abundance of timber
there's so many trees in fact that mills
can basically name their price for the
logs that they take in
and saw into boards the supply and
demand is so out of whack that
analysts and a lot of investors in
sawmill companies think it could be a
decade or two
before enough trees are cut down that
supply and demand
is back in balance even with the
increased demand we're seeing today for
wood products
earl barr says the consolidation of the
market has also made it difficult to
sell timber
20 years ago if we'd have a track of
timber that we would have put up for
bids we'd have gotten at least 10
independent bids competitive bids for
that track of wood
now we're seeing fewer than five if
you're lucky we're not looking at what
is happening to our markets
are we playing on a level playing field
are we
able to put our trees into a truly
competitive marketplace
analysts do expect lumber prices will
eventually go down
but with the housing market continuing
to run hot the price continues to rise